around 2010 Arcane Studios was not
looking too great having produced no
games of their own and only those made
for other developers like Ubisoft or
valve they didn't have a lot of
credibility in the gaming industry and
it also didn't help that the games they
did make weren't really received well
either however not long into the new
decade Bethesda would contact them and
offer a deal that would change the
company forever Bethesda hire them to
create a stealth-based game and after
years of development this would be known
as Dishonored this game had put them on
the map as the game had received
numerous nominations and rewards across
various categories and it gave the team
at Arcana platform to stand on within
the gaming World almost as high as some
of the Giants in the industry today but
in 2014 things would change once again
as while part of the team was busy
working on a Dishonored sequel everyone
else was working on something quite
bizarre prey will always be known as
arcane's first child this is the first
game they were able to create that they
wanted to make not something they were
contracted to make this would lead to
the team making this game much
differently than the reward winning
title instead of having an expansive
world only gated off by levels like
Dishonored they would opt for a larger
Dynamic world that would constantly
adapt and change throughout the game
where players wouldn't have to just
think about the challenges within the
level itself but all the obstacles and
the map around them however lots of
decisions led to the game going down the
wrong path in 2011 Bethesda would
acquire the intellectual property rights
to prey the one from 2006 but it
wouldn't be much later until they
finally used the IP's namesake for a
project at E3 2016 Bethesda would
announce a reboot of prey which seemed
to generate some hype and Intrigue the
problem started to arise though as some
were still unaware of the game being a
reboot and simply casted it aside While
others was still riding the high of
Dishonored and were eagerly waiting for
the sequel while not paying attention to
anything else as if things weren't
already bad enough there was disputes
over the prey trademark and Bethesda
withheld review copies of the game until
the release date which led to a lot of
the negative assumptions about the
game's gameplay and its performance
however after some time prey were
unfavorable reviews among critics but it
still wasn't enough as the sales were 60
percent less than Dishonored 2 and that
game was still behind in sales compared
to Dishonored one so while we don't know
actual numbers they didn't seem very
high this whole synopsis brings me to my
actual point prey did not receive the
love it deserved I've been playing this
game for the past few weeks and at least
within recent memory it's the best
immersive Sim and Story game I've played
in a long time it's one of the very few
games I regret never playing on release
its story player freedom and gameplay
all mixed together created this
fantastic experience and it's one that
I'll never forget so today I want to
take some time to discuss my experience
with prey and maybe even convince you to
give this game a try just like I did
without further Ado let's get started
prey is a complex and mind-bending game
so firstly we need to discuss what it is
despite what the steam page says prey is
a first person immersive Sim the last
word may be a bit foreign to some so
think of games like Deus Ex Dishonored
and System Shock the point being that
the game provides with a plethora of
options you can use to complete your
current objective Dishonored was
universally praised for this style of
gameplay and so was prey sadly this is
as much as I can say do the nature of
the game talking about it anymore would
be entering spoiler territory so I'll be
adding a warning now and then once again
when we get to the story section this
upcoming portion spoils the intro of
prey arguably the most important part of
the game so skip to the gameplay section
if you still want to listen but want to
avoid story spoilers if you've been
watching my content for a bit then you
know this isn't the first time I'm
saying this and it also won't be the
last but the intro which I consider to
be the first hour of any game is the
most important part of the game and prey
might actually have the best opening
hour of a game I've ever played after
picking our preferred gender we as
Morgan you wake up in an apartment deep
within the city we get a call from our
brother Alex who wants to meet with us
the apartment has a lot of interactable
objects from bottles to books to our
workstation it's getting us acquainted
with the game without even telling us
what to do we can't leave until we put
on our suit so in the meantime the
player can test their controls their
settings and allow them to get a good
feel for the game before they head out
too many games seem to just jump the
player into conflict or obvious
tutorials that it seems like you're
being dragged alongside the game prey is
all about providing the player with
choices and options so it seems quite
fitting that the very first objective
doesn't start until we're ready we go
outside and are told that the helicopter
our brother sent is waiting for us the
next two minutes are probably the best
two minutes of the entire game not only
is it because of the unique decision to
add 3D in World text to present the
studios in-game but it's what these two
minutes represent 78 degrees clear skies
all the way
foreign
all about interactivity and creativity
one of the most memorable parts of this
game has none of that all you do is just
move the camera that's all you can
interact with but like I said it's what
this scene represents that makes it so
memorable this small part of the game
was able to Captivate the player in
numerous ways like the gorgeous views
from the helicopter and of course the
music the song playing in the background
is called everything is going to be okay
the song conveys a sense of warmth
happiness and excitement like I said
I've been playing this game for the past
three weeks and not a single day has
gone by that I haven't listened to this
song this along with the entire
soundtrack was composed mostly by Mick
Gordon yes the one that created the
music for Doom he's clearly a talented
composer and his work on prey was no
exception we'll talk about that a bit
later in the video but for now let's
continue after landing the helicopter we
take an elevator meet with our brother
and then are told to go through a series
of tests this is another tutorial
disguised as a test simulation like
picking up objects hiding and climbing
throughout these tests things start to
be become a little puzzling while the
researchers assure us we're doing fine
their commentary is quite contradictory
I'm sorry can someone please
Isaac Simmons I installed exactly what
Tina brought down did you double check
speaker's still on
I apologize Morgan we're having some
trouble with the equipment this comes to
a startling halt during our very last
test we're nearly through it
for this next part I'm going to display
an image I want you to take a good look
at it in a moment I'm going to ask you
what uh
with my coffee
that's empty
oh my God
so it was a little unexpected but this
is great now as the conflict has started
and we can finally get into the game
good morning Morgan today is Monday
March 15 2032.
I lied we are back at our apartment the
game is trying to toy with the player
what we saw was 100 real but because
they sent us back to the apartment it's
trying to convince us that everything we
saw was fake someone or something is
screwing with us what we saw was real
and nothing inside this tiny apartment
can convince us otherwise since the
player has already been here it's quite
easy to know where to go next which is
down the hall to the helipad except that
door isn't there anymore and the lady we
saw out in the hallway is now dead this
sets in a feeling of tension essentially
confirming that what we saw during the
test did happen and is in some dream
there is some alien creature in the
building and were being hunted the issue
is that the areas we went down before
are gone and the only way out seems to
be the balcony
foreign
this is the reason I said skip this part
to avoid spoilers this is
single-handedly one of the most powerful
and confusing scenes in the entire game
anyone who has ever played prey knows
about the intro and it's quite hard to
forget this entire time you were made to
believe that you were in some large
apartment when in fact you were in some
facility being monitored presumably by
the researchers from earlier it's a
short but powerful scene that is
wonderfully executed as we walk around
the facility still coming to terms with
what we just uncovered we engage in
combat with the mimic for the first time
it's quite an easy fight that I'm almost
100 certain the mimic does not hate you
but rather just runs away because of how
unique the enemy we face is having the
ability to turn into other objects we
not only have to get accustomed to
controls to combat but also with attack
strategy for most games the first enemy
is slow weak and almost impossible to
lose to however prey refused to pull the
same tactic and instead put us right
into the deep end showing us how these
enemies work and attack having them not
actually attack us does fall in that
same description before where they're
impossible to lose to but because the
enemy is a bit complex and is constantly
toying with us by shape-shifting then
running away it's both a perfect display
of the basics of Praise combat but also
making sure the player doesn't get
punished for just trying to learn
something new after this we uncover on
other Secrets the room and the
helicopter we rode on is also fake if we
go to the second floor we can further
confirm our suspicions once again as the
walls created a simulation that made it
look like we were in a helicopter being
flown across the city it's quite clear
this entire intro was made to invoke
newborn's feelings from confusion to
mystery to even questioning everything
we see these emotions and feelings we
have will be key as we continue the game
into the story progressing further into
the level we once again get introduced
to more combat except this time it's a
little different it's now a 4v1 room
filled with a ton of objects these
mimics could be anywhere and anything I
also like the small detail of the chair
in the middle of the hallway as it seems
way too out of place to just be a chair
however it really is just a chair making
you go crazy thinking how is that not a
mimic this can continues to bury deep
into your mind is now you start
expecting duplicates of items assuming
that they may actually be real until the
mimic finally reveals itself it's also
here where the game provides you with a
few options of Escape there's a door
hatch as well as a regular locked door
this is the start of balance the game
tries to achieve and this balance will
continue throughout the game and other
aspects we can head right into the hatch
and leave we escape the mimics and live
to fight another day but if you face
your fears of the mimics you can push
into the main office and grab the key
card you will more than likely need to
face all the mimics to get there but
you'll be rewarded with a way out all
the items they dropped and the
confidence in your combat capabilities
but the game doesn't want you to be too
proud of yourself as once you escape you
meet another alien much different than
the one we just faced it's here where we
get our first gun the glue Cannon this
is by far the most versatile weapon I've
ever used the glue gun's primary
function is to glue things it touches so
now we can freeze the mimics and allow
us to get a sneak attack bonus against
them while this is great we will
discover later it has way more uses than
this in typical fashion question we also
get introduced to the abilities and
skills we'll be upgrading by using
neural mods I'll explain this more in
the gameplay section but this is where
they first appear to our right is the
door we need to go through to exit this
facility or at least one room of the
facility this place is called the lobby
so maybe we could use this area to
escape out the front doors except for
the very final time we are being lied to
so not only were we not in a real
apartment the helicopter ride was also
fake and everything we thought was real
was not and to top it all off we aren't
even on Earth We're on a [ __ ] space
station all of this everything we have
experienced from the very second of the
game was in space near the moon I'm
really hoping that if you haven't played
prey you aren't watching this part of
the video because the emotions you'll
feel in this intro are unlike any other
that's why I honed in on that song from
the beginning the song was even lying to
us painting us this picture that the
game was going to be this bright and
beautiful world obviously not everyone
was going to believe it was as sunshine
and rainbows as it seemed but I feel
like no one would have guessed it would
have been this deep in betrayal and
deception I also love the irony of the
song title everything is going to be
okay when in fact it's the complete
opposite as you may expect tons of time
went into this part of the game
especially with the glass breaking scene
there's a documentary from the people at
noclip where they talk to the team about
this intro specifically I won't say
everything is to completely steal from
the video if you want to watch it
yourself however some incredible
discoveries are brought up during the
interviews from the very beginning the
devs were hinting at this mystery as
when inspecting the floor you could find
marks as if walls or items were being
moved they also placed the fish tank
outside the room specifically near the
area where you pick up the wrench the
devs also purposely made the tank and
its fish bright so that the player might
be inclined to hit it with the wrench
when the player hits the glass it breaks
meaning that the other glass will break
if it's hit with the wrench which of
course leads to the glass breaking scene
the one thing the team at Arcane wanted
from the very beginning was for us to
break the glass the emotional feeling is
much more impactful when we uncover the
mystery ourselves and something I didn't
notice until watching this video that
the fish tank was actually a viable
option leaving the room you don't get to
have the Cinematic feeling that you
would get normally but it's another way
of escaping one thing that definitely
needs to be brought up is the amount of
skill that's needed to actually
conceptualize and make this thing come
to life this whole thing is fake so
things need to be made that way and most
games and elevator is used to load and
remove assets to give the player the
feeling that they're actually going up
and down in an elevator except prey
takes this a little bit too literally
the only thing that moves in the
elevator is the number counting down
everything else is moving around you so
that it gives the illusion that you're
actually moving down a few floors in a
way you could see the researchers as the
developers and Morgan as us the devs are
trying to convince us that what they
built is real just like the researchers
built the facility to convince Morgan
what he's seeing is real priz intro is
by far one of the most iconic intros in
gaming due to its ability to deceive the
player but also never outright tell the
player what is real or not but instead
let them figure it out for themselves we
didn't need to screw with the
workstation and discover that the
Looking Glass Technology they used was
to full us but it feels better when
you're rewarded for doing something
yourself rather than when the game
motions you towards something against
your own volition like I said earlier
the intro is the most important part of
the game this is the area of time that
most players will end up reaching while
not many may make it to the ending those
who have purchased the game will see the
intro and if you can hook them here then
you might be able to hook them for the
rest of the game and prey's intro goes
above and beyond to do just that by
letting the player do all the work
technically we are now finished with the
intro but there is still one last thing
to do and that's to go to Morgan's
office upon entering the office we watch
a message that Morgan left for himself
until our brother purposely interrupts
it so we don't discover the truth this
is where we officially start the next
chapter of the game I'll get into that
message later in the story section
because now we can talk about the
gameplay so praise gameplay I feel is
more akin to a survival horror game once
again something the steam page won't
tell you you go around in Looper
materials ammo and other equipment while
dealing with the enemies in your way
most of the time you'll just be barely
getting by with the equipment you have
which is why I've always considered at
least the survival game the horror part
is subjective depending on how much this
will terrify you regardless it
definitely has the elements of a
survival game you can even enable
certain survival options like traumas
weapon integration and oxygen level if
you want all this is well and good but
what's the actual gameplay Loop what are
you going to be doing throughout the
game this is a little hard to answer due
to the many different variables but at
its most basic form you'll be searching
desks boxes trash cans tables pretty
much anywhere for trash items you can
then take these items to the two most
important objects in the game the
recycler and the fabricator each item in
the game has a specific material in it
such as organic mineral synthetic or
exotic all these items can be placed
into the recycler and turned into those
materials you can then take those
materials to the fabricator to make
certain plans you can unlock these plans
by finding specific fabricator plans
scattered throughout the station this at
its core is the most basic form of its
gameplay finding items turning them into
materials then using those materials to
make new items while Scavenging for
supplies you won't be just finding
random trash there could be things like
Med kits neural mods but more
importantly new weapons prey has certain
weapons that are very standard in games
like this a pistol a shotgun and a melee
weapon but prey also adds more unique
weapons like a stun gun or qbeam but
there's also some extremely well thought
out grenades and two of the coolest
weapons to be put in a game like this
the grenades are incredibly unique there
is no typical frag grenade or incendiary
that does damage they're all situational
grenades that are extremely powerful the
first one you might come across is the
recycler charge it works like a mobile
recycler machine anything you throw at
it can be sucked inside and turned into
materials and this goes for you and the
enemies this on the surface is pretty
good for gaining more materials you
could stack some items together and
throw a recycler for some easy materials
but nothing in this game should ever be
seen as simple what's stopping me from
throwing this at a door I can't unlock
or a box that's too heavy to move it
gets the materials yes but it also opens
up New Paths like couldn't before this
is what prey is all about using the
simple mechanics of an item to do
bizarre things and I think that's truly
what its gameplay Loop and tails the
other grenades while not as creative as
the recycler are still worth keeping
Typhon lures are used to lure enemies
away from an area EMP Chargers can
disable power to a box allowing you to
not get shocked or disable an electric
enemy and no wave transmitters can
disable Typhon abilities making mimics
come out of hiding or just stopping them
from attacking all these grenades can be
placed as well so you could even light
traps for the Typhon why bother killing
the enemy yourself when they could just
walk over a recycler and kill themselves
and that's truly the fun of this game's
combat yes shooting an enemy and killing
them using conventional means is still
fun but when you use the equipment you
have in different ways it's much more
enjoyable and they not only encourage
this style of gameplay but you could be
rewarded for doing so the glue Cannon
and the bulk Caster are perfect for this
explanation the bull Caster is seen as a
utility weapon it literally shoots foam
bolts so obviously this won't help us
kill anything so it helps us in other
ways if you have the right angle you
could shoot the workstation screen so
that the doors can unlock and allow you
to get inside it's a genius weapon that
continues to hone in on on the play how
you want gameplay but like I said it's
quite obvious from the moment you pick
it up what it's actually used for the
glue gun is a different story the first
thing we see of the glue gun is a mimic
trapped in glue so this tells us it's a
combat weapon however it's way more
versatile than that as multiple times we
can see these makeshift stairs and walls
full of them this is showing the player
that what you are seeing is possible to
do the best example I can show was when
I was at the very top of the station to
get into this office you need to take
the gravity lift but it was out of power
and I couldn't use it but with a little
bit of glue I was able to climb up the
side and get into the office without
even needing the code this is the main
reason I love the glue gun so much it's
because it's a versatile weapon with
Endless Possibilities disguised as a
combat weapon another nice display of
detail is that every weapon minus the
bolt Caster has a little display of ammo
and I think that's wonderful as the HUD
for this game is very minimal with only
the three bars at the bottom being
consistent throughout the whole game but
it doesn't even stop at the weapons as
there are still abilities and chipsets
you can unlock the chipsets of these
pieces you can attach to your suit and
psychoscope that can provide upgrades
like discovering where hidden mimics are
and adding extra resistance to certain
attacks they are minor but meaningful
upgrades as they air passive Buffs but
the skills originally you start out with
three human trees these can upgrade
things like Health stamina and strength
but eventually you'll get three more
trees all of which have Typhon abilities
using the power of the Typhon against
them you can change the entire situation
in front of you I won't go over
everything individually but there is a
large variety of them like a basic
damage ability called kinetic blast or
even being able to summon your own
Phantom from a corpse called The Phantom
Genesis all these abilities work
seamlessly into the gameplay allowing
for your creativity to shine there are
many ways that you can utilize all these
abilities and options at the same time
and it really encourages you to play
your own way all of these abilities
though have to be bought using neural
mods so everyone will be in different
spots at certain points you can either
find the neural mods or find the
fabrication plan to make some if someone
takes the time to scavenge the station
then they'll be pretty well equipped to
deal with most situations head on but if
you didn't find anything you'll need to
be more creative in your approach even
if you do have lots of neural mods it
all depends on what you chose Typhon
abilities are nice and very effective at
dealing with the Typhon but use too many
in the turrets on the station may
mistake you for one with that in mind
maybe you don't want to use the Typhon
abilities but then you're losing out on
a plethora of options those abilities
give you this is what I meant by that
balance earlier choosing to either
dedicate more time to search areas for
Loot and maybe finding neural mods or
skipping it entirely and missing out on
beneficial upgrades it makes the
experience different from other players
and leads to a lot of those I didn't
know that moments where even after the
third playthrough you might still find
new ways to explore a location or take
an enemy down however that balance
doesn't just affect the exploration but
also its combat the game constantly
makes you feel inferior then gives you
strong weapons and upgrades only to make
you feel inferior once again in the
beginning we had nothing but a wrench
against the Typhon but then we were
given the glue gun now we have something
to combat them but then the game
introduces Phantoms and while you may
think it's easy arrange glue gun is not
going to be enough but not to worry as
the game will give us pistols and
shotguns and upgrades but then the
enemies will also get stronger with
different variations with fire or
electricity some can create clones ones
that can be invisible you get my point
rarely in this game did I actually feel
powerful I was by definition a powerful
being but because the enemies were
getting stronger and more diverse I was
struggling at certain points however I
think this is a good thing if everything
was easy to kill then what's the point
of being creative when running and
gunning is both easier and faster
enemies will also respawn when you load
back into an area so if you go from the
lobby to deep storage then back to the
lobby newer enemies will be there it's
not exactly like traditional respawning
because it's newer enemies or stronger
versions of current enemies so it shows
how the ship acts like an ecosystem
where enemies will wander into areas
you've cleared out on top of not feeling
powerful I never really felt safe either
games like Resident Evil for example
have a safe room hidden away from the
danger where no enemies can get inside
it also has a save station and most
likely a box with all your gear you
could keep the game running and walk
away from the game without any worry as
nothing can enter but with prey I can
only think of one spot where I felt this
way which was the main elevator none of
the typical areas are obviously safe I
can't just pick a room and stand there
which is to be expected there are lots
of areas though that have permanent
locks on them you can lock the door
permanently and nothing will get inside
but this isn't some typical enemy
obviously the Typhon are different not
only can the mimics be literally any
item in the room many Phantoms have
hidden behind desks and doors without
even me noticing I was originally going
to add Morgan's office to this list as
well but at least to my knowledge Morgan
does not have a lock on his office door
and I paid the price for this as a
phantom that was searching for me had
just walked right in the elevator is the
only place in the game where you can
feel safe until they spawn a phantom in
there to try to toy with you not feeling
safe is a terrifying feeling but it's
accurate to what's going on you're
trapped on a space station where the
alien species roaming the Halls
outnumber you greatly so you should feel
terrified and it's a nice correlation to
the game's title prey the Typhon aren't
the prey here we are the prey and that's
why at all times you never truly feel
safe and Powerful when playing many
games make the player feel weak by
giving them nothing to defend themselves
with but not many games can pull this
off while also giving the player dozens
of weapons and abilities and I think
that deserves a lot of respect the
gameplay is great but what really ties
this all together is the actual station
itself Talos one is a wonderfully made
setting for the game the station is both
beautiful inside and outside and the
fact that you can go outside the space
station was a great decision as it
complements the travel aspect of the
game in the very beginning not every
area of Talos one will be unlocked but
after a few main quests eventually
you'll have free access to the entire
station however due to its design you
can't simply go where you want certain
sections are only available from other
sections prey combats this problem by
providing three fast ways to go around
the map you have the main elevator that
takes you from the arborium lobby and
life support this large tunnel called
the guts which connects the cargo base
psychotronics and shuttle Bay to the
arborium and lastly the exterior that
connects a majority of the area is on
Talos one together all these ways of
travel are beneficial in their own way
but also have some hurdles the player
must overcome during or before its use
the main elevator is by far the
preferred option since it's fast and
connects the three main sections of the
station but to even start the elevator
you have to destroy a telepath not only
an enemy you haven't faced yet but the
arena for the area is so tiny it's hard
to find any cover the guts can be very
useful especially from the top all the
way to the bottom but the guts is filled
with enemies and is also very dangerous
and the exterior of Talos is quite safe
minus a few enemies but you do actually
have to find the airlocks in their
respective places first in order to
enter the area so this isn't for
discovering new areas it's for going to
areas you've already gone to as you'll
notice none of them overpower each other
personally I did use the elevator the
most but each option does have its
benefits and because none of them
overpower each other you can simply
bypass the issues by just using one for
the entire game besides the amounts of
options for fast travel if you want to
call it that having even one of these
would be great the these areas are large
and filled with life not literally but
you get what I mean there are multiple
floors of rooms to explore so it can be
quite tedious having to go from one end
of the station to the other without any
assistance but more importantly they
make sense this leads me to my next
point which is that the areas are not
only gorgeous and expansive but they
feel like they belong why wouldn't you
have an elevator on a space station if
my knowledge is correct the space
station is 700 meters tall that's almost
as high as the tallest building in the
world climbing that many steps would
probably kill people from exhaustion
before they even reach their destination
each of these rooms serves a purpose not
only for the player but for the station
itself the space station is separated
into three main sections the Executive
Research and Engineering Branch all the
engineering locations are at the bottom
this is where all the hardware equipment
and maintenance facilities exist there
is the power plant which holds the
reactor that powers the entire ship the
cargo bay is responsible for shipment
processing and life support handles all
the air and water filtration systems
this is the core of the station as
nothing can function properly with
without these working so you can just
look at this place as metaphorically
holding the station Together Like Glue
the middle is the research division that
has the largest number of rooms most of
which relate to experimentation my
favorite part about this area is that
they were made for specific reasons it's
not just some science Wing that exists
that has everything and anything Talus
one has separate areas dedicated to
specific types of research it's got an
area for neural mods an area for Typhon
research and another for hardware and
weapons the last section is the
executive division where the crew
quarters Arboretum and deep storage are
deep storage is used for storing all the
station's research the Arboretum has
Gardens for Botanical experiments and is
just gorgeous to look at thanks to the
windows surrounding it so you can see
the ever expanding Universe all these
areas also have at least one fabricator
and recycler and even a security station
seeing as this station is used to get
the best results fast for their research
they need all the equipment they need
within the same building the security
station also has utilities that the
security would only need to know like
the map of the area the status of the
Escape pods and even where the crewmates
are on the ship since they're all
wearing tracking bracelets the best
example though of a believable
environment has to be the crew quarters
there are crew cabins and recreational
Services scattered throughout this area
of the station some of the crew have
separate rooms but some just sleep in
bunk beds but Within These specific
rooms are things that complement the
person living there a few of the
crewmates are actually a part of a d d
group so those players will have the
game's books or sheets based on their
character in their room or on their
workstation the game is also displaying
a sense of hierarchy that is respected
amongst the station's inhabitants as
there's actually a gravity lift that can
take you to the executive suites I've
always said that if a game's setting
seems like it could function normally
without the need of the player then they
did a good job and Arcane really took
the time to develop this not only
gorgeous but believable space station
that doesn't just stop at the locations
of the areas but the areas themselves
things aren't perfectly in order and are
normal there was literally just an
outbreak So Random garbage on the floor
a door being unlocked experiments left
unfinished all of it makes sense and
then there's also the amount of effort
that went into not only making the
locations look great and feel real but
also making it fun from a gameplay
perspective there are pipes going across
the rooms that we can use to spy on the
Typhon we can go into events connecting
other areas and ignore the Typhon all of
this needs to be taken into
consideration when making Talos one
because it doesn't matter how good it
looks if the player doesn't enjoy
playing then they won't enjoy the game
everything we've discussed so far is
great on its own but what ties it all
together is the music praise music is
simply wonderful I've already talked
about the one in the intro and mentioned
that praise music was mostly composed by
Mick Gordon and this is actually the
most depressing part about this game
prayer never got any nominations for its
music and while Mick Gordon has done
press conferences on his music for Doom
none of them were made for prey I just
wish I was able to understand the
thought process behind the instruments
and the equipment he used but that sadly
won't happen regardless prey has some
incredible music that fits for the given
situation their exploration tracks and
combat tracks like any typical gaming
soundtrack and also other songs that you
can only hear in game on the speakers
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
where do you believe
[Music]
you'll notice for certain songs like
Typhon voices or no gravity that the
songs aren't strong like a combat theme
but they also aren't some calming
Ambience they're sort of a mix of bolts
the game is creepy and terrifying so the
music should reflect that weirdly enough
the song semi-sacred geometry while it's
sung by a woman in the game it's
actually sung by a guy named Matt
Pearsall in the official soundtrack I
genuinely have no reason why this is the
case one big problem I have with the
soundtrack though is that it's just too
short only having around 14 songs now
that number could seem fairly average to
some but it's not really the number of
tracks per se that bothers me it's a
fact that there is a ton of music not
put in the official soundtrack and It's
upsetting because some of this is
arguably the best in the game
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
if you've played prey there's no doubt
in my mind that you've heard this music
while playing and that's why it makes it
all the more upsetting it's just
confusing why this is not a part of the
official soundtrack but I guess we'll
never know the only thing that remains
of the original game is its story once
again spoiler warning ahead if you don't
want to hear stuff about the story then
skip ahead to the DLC so instead of
going back to where we left off in the
intro some background knowledge is
necessary this is the typical who what
where when why questions that are
required to give the story actual
meaning and explain how things got to
where they are praiseworld is like ours
except in prey the space race between
Russia and the United States accelerated
much faster than ours during an
investigation Mission regarding a
shuttle that went missing in 1960 two
cosmonauts would relay their video feed
to the Russian space command and capture
the very first Typhon this was
immediately labeled the state's secret
and was never shared with anyone until
1962 when Russia would ask the U.S
president John F Kennedy to assist in
containing the threat history Buffs May
recognize that in our world JFK would be
assassinated a year later later but in
Praise universe that assassination was a
failure and JFK lived through that day
in history eventually the US would start
building a giant space station so that
they could study the Typhon and while
successful for a while the typh had
broke out and killed everyone on the
ship the station would lay dormant for a
while until a newly made Mega
Corporation Called Transtar would
purchase it and in a few years create
Talos won Transtar is led by an
anonymous board of directors that no one
knows about except the two faces of the
company being Morgan's parents who are
Katherine and William U eventually his
brother Alex would become the CEO of the
company and be the head of Talos one he
would then eventually convince Morgan to
join the tables one research team to
which Morgan accepted fast forward to
where we left off after getting to
Morgan's office we played the video that
was saved on our computer working goes
on to explain that they've been testing
new neural mods with Typhon DNA so that
the neural patterns of both a Typhon and
a human brain could connect only
problems that when you would try to
uninstall these neuromods the user loses
all the memories during the time it was
implanted so hypothetically if you put
in the neuroma and then uninstalled it a
month later you would lose every memory
you had for the past month to circumvent
this issue they've developed a method of
getting people back up to speed but if
they skip that process you could force
someone to live one day for their entire
life which is exactly what happened to
Morgan but for three whole years while
watching the rest of the video Morgan
goes on to explain something but is
interrupted by Alex and refuses to let
us finish the video until he can explain
himself obviously we're not going to
listen so we leave the office and try to
reset the power to the Looking Glass
it's important when making a story to
not only have a strong beginning and end
but give the player actual reason some
RPGs can struggle with this concept and
not give a player a reason to play the
story other than the shiny loot at the
end because if we think about things
from the perspective of our created
character what's stopping us from doing
the task we were given answers like loot
or new armor doesn't make sense because
that's what we the player wants not what
our character wants fallet is always a
great example that I tend to reference a
lot since the protagonist wants to find
their son they aren't going to ditch
their kid and take up a new life as a
farmer that's their own on so it's a
perfect motive for the protagonist to
venture into the Wasteland the good
thing about prey is that they have
created an environment where the
opposite won't ever happen our motive is
Morgan is finding our brother and
finding a way off the ship prey
perfectly displays a current short-term
goal and a long-term goal Alex is our
brother so we obviously want to make
sure he's okay but also question him as
assuming he stays true to his word we
may discover why he never gave our
memories back and if possible our
long-term goal could even be furthered
if we complete the short-term goal
however after this the main story does
hit a low point for a while the quests
are a bunch of backtracking and
retrieving items the whole experience
isn't all bad since the gameplay will
take the reins for the time being until
you get to the quest so when you're
playing and going from quest to Quest
with combat in between it's great but if
we analyze the quest just by itself it's
honestly quite boring after we leave
Morgan's office we head to the hardware
labs to reinstall the Looking Glass then
head back to Morgan's office to hear the
final part of the message after the
message we go to psychotronics to get
the psychoscope before going to the guts
to the Arboretum and then into the deep
storage before we realize deep storage
can't be opened without a passphrase as
we go to the crew Annex to get the
password head back to deep storage
except Alex locks Us in so we gotta grab
data vaults and try to escape which
caused us to get shot in space with the
only entrance between the cargo bay
where all the crews hold up that was
about half the story summed up in a few
seconds there are obviously
conversations that keep you interested
in the story but the amount of
backtracking and fetch questing is
insane like I said when it works
together with the gameplay it's
wonderful as the gameplay and
exploration may go into all these areas
fun especially since most of them are
new areas you haven't visited yet but if
we just analyze the story by itself then
it's clear that it's boring during this
time the player will discover that
Morgan hasn't talked once despite having
a voice actor for the role and these
weird cutscenes during certain parts of
the game these are quite vital to the
main story so keep these in mind for
later during this story you'll encounter
a few crewmates that you can talk to
they all seem fairly nice but there are
emails and audio logs that make you and
your brother out to be not the nicest of
people so given the context why would
you help these people at all especially
when you realize that they were willing
to look the other way while one of their
own members was subjected to constant
experiments now given the amount of
people and how large the ship is it's
fair to assume not everyone knew but
clearly some people did know and since
we don't know who this action sort of
labels all of them being the problem not
just a few people the game plays into
this idea as you'll receive side quests
that make you go out of your way to do
some random tasks one of the researchers
Dr iguay is trapped in a storage device
and is running out of air if we save him
he's thankful for our help and will be
stationed at Morgan's office he'll then
give you the task of retrieving a music
sample of a famous musician Dr igwa
claims it's the last living part of him
and with it we could still be able to
hear this man's work it's completely
irrelevant to the main plot and makes
you go out of your way to do so these
play into the mindset of how you would
see the researchers after discovering
what they put you through and it's not
only extremely important for the story
but an incredible way of giving the
player the freedom to choose another
wonderful Quest is about the chef and
the crew quarters you can find him
hiding in the kitchen from some Typhon
his name is William Russell but if you
search her wrong you'll notice that
Will's voice and vase do not the person
in front of you originally I thought
this was a glitch or an oversight by
Arcane until the chef rewarded me with
the gear in the fridge and then trapped
me inside he is actually an escaped
volunteer and is trying to get revenge
on us not only is the concept of this
Quest great but just starting it is even
better once you've escaped the fridge he
leaves and you won't find him you'll
eventually have to follow a breadcrumb
trail of clues that could lead you to
him but while doing this and even just
exploring the ship in general you could
trip a recycler charge and get killed he
has left traps everywhere on the ship
and you'll have no idea where they are
unless you look really close the ending
of this Quest was also fairly well done
where he tries to get you one last time
but it fails and you end his life
someone else you'll encounter early in
the game is January and December both
are operators just like the ones we see
throughout the station except these were
made by Morgan after he discovered he
was being subjected to constant testing
there's also a possible October and
November According to some notes so it
seems like Morgan would discover that he
was being tested on then make backups of
his mind so he could catch himself speed
the reason why there's so many is
probably because Morgan has a chance to
be different so Morgan made October to
catch himself up to speed then when he
made November to catch the other up to
speed with a better plan and on and on
until we get January this is backed up
by what December and January's end goals
are January's end goal is blowing up the
base along with the Typhon on the
station but December's is to hop into
Alex's Escape pod and leave dooming
everyone so that leads me to believe
that there were multiple times Morgan
changed his plan after hearing the
previous Morgan's original plan knowing
this we can continue with the plan or
the other alternative is to deploy a
null wave device this functions like the
no wave grenade but will eliminate all
the Typhon on the ship after a few more
story quests of talking to Alex and
retrieving things you're about to choose
an ending and finish the game until prey
throws one final wrench in the plans
which is doll doll was hired by Morgan's
parents to wipe out everyone on the
station including Alex and Morgan he
even comes equipped with his own Army of
military operators the decisions you can
make during this part of the quest is
fantastic and very expensive but it's
also so unpleasant there are numerous
ways this Quest can end Dahl attempts to
deceive You by acting as a hurt
scientist named Luther glass this is to
lure you into a trap and kill you he'll
then try to shut off the oxygen to the
ship killing the crew unless you stop
him he is actually in the next room and
you can not only stop the oxygen from
depleting but also kill him if you want
to however if you save Dr iGuy he offers
an alternative which is to knock him out
and wipe his memory since he's the only
one with the skills to fly the shuttle
he came in on you could wipe his memory
and make him escort the crew off the
station before he realizes he was being
played if you don't find him in the
other room you can also find him at the
Arboretum trying to kill Alex like I
said the quest is incredible and so
expansive that you would have to run
through it multiple times just to get
everything done what ruins this Quest
though is his operators doll's military
operators not only have the health but
they have the numbers they are strong
they hit hard and there's a lot of them
they're not like the typhoon where you
can come up with routes and ways around
them they aren't even like the corrupted
operators because there is never this
many at one time what makes things is
worse is that most of his quests involve
a time limit so you have to act fast and
quick while also being lasered by a
dozen operators while I did try to fight
back in the beginning I pretty much gave
up almost immediately and just ran
through the quest trying to ignore them
it goes against what this game is about
outsmarting your opponent and using the
abilities and weapons you have at your
disposal to turn the tide of battle in
your favor but not once did I ever feel
like I had the upper hand in any
engagement now that we have covered just
about everything we can finally talk
about the ending as long as you do
either January or Alex's ending which is
using the null wave device or blowing up
Talos one you will get the ending
December's ending with the Escape pod
gives you a game over not an ending it
also Clues you into what's going on
assuming you're like me in didn't do
this ending first you're in for a wild
surprise after the ending we get the
credits then a black screen which
transitions into the after credit scene
which is the real ending of the game
everything we did was a simulation and
what we went through was a
reconstruction of Morgan's memories when
the Typhon actually attacked the crew of
Talos 1. we're also being judged based
on our actions which are a few key
features to get a good review we need to
not kill lots of crew members who killed
the Imposter Chef spare the volunteer
prisoner saved Dr igwe and Makaya and do
their respective quests if you did these
well enough then you succeed if you fail
all across the board they'll kill you
immediately I know I haven't discussed a
few of these choices so allow me to
explain later in the game you'll find
most of the crew in the cargo bay they
want your help by killing the Typhon and
setting up turrets to defend them if
most or all of them die then you will
fail this part the last one is a toss-up
in terms of my personal feelings because
we find a prisoner locked in a test
chamber we can either kill him and get a
lot of exotic material or let him live
and he'll give us the code to the Armory
you could also save beforehand get the
code then revert to last save and open
the armory which is what I did
regardless you're being graded on your
moral compass and if someone like him
should die or not you can read his file
and discover that he did some illegal
things to kids I refuse to elaborate any
further on that statement assuming I
couldn't save scum I would have easily
killed him because of his crimes but
that is a bad grade on the test and the
only one I received the reason we're
being graded is because Morgan did save
the people of Talos one through some
means but the Typhon still made it to
Earth Alex is trying to save Humanity by
building a bridge between the Typhon and
humans instead of doing what he
originally did which was putting Typhon
DNA into humans which is the neuromods
he wants to instead take the human DNA
and put it into a Typhon which is why we
are put in the simulation to determine
if we showed enough empathy and care for
the crew aboard Talos one despite all
the testing Morgan went through and the
fact that it were technically a phantom
if we succeed then we're given two
options we can join Alex and the rest or
kill Alex and become like every other
Typhon dooming the world it's a
wonderful ending and something I did not
see coming there were some signs that
led to this conclusion but nothing was
concrete enough for me to know it was
extremely well made and planned out so
that the breadcrumbs of what's going on
like the flashbacks and the numerous
discussions about being humans with
emotions were shared but in a perfect
way that the player did not see coming
but only realized what it was when the
moment was right putting its simply it's
just genius storytelling prey is not
without its issues individually the
beginning and end were fantastic and
some of the highlights of my play time
but the middle did sour the experience a
bit if you wanted to buy prey for just
the story despite what I just said I
would still give it my recommendation as
the beginning and end are just that good
in 2018 with the release of survival
mode and New Game Plus Arcane would also
release its first DLC called Moon crash
there was another DLC released months
later called Typhon Hunter which is a
5v1 versus mode where one person is
Morgan tries to kill the other five
players who are hiding his mimics I was
going to cover this DLC as well but not
only could I not actually figure out
where to play the DLC I'm assuming the
servers are long dead by now anyway
regardless Moon crash is way different
than prey Moon crashes prey but if it
was a roguelike roguelike was the last
genre I expected to play in a game like
this so it came as a surprise funny
enough this would also be my first
experience with roguelikes I've heard
people say death Loop was a roguelike
but I've also heard people argue it's a
rogue light but in terms of the actual
popular roguelikes of the genre such as
Hades or risk of rain I've never played
any of them and just in case you're like
me and haven't touched this genre either
it usually encompasses things like
permadeath randomized levels among other
key features I was definitely a little
nervous going into this but I was
intrigued to play it because I've never
played something like this before and to
summarize my play time it was fantastic
Moon crash has a lot to go over so
instead of going into a long discussion
about my thoughts I need to explain what
it's about Moon crash starts with us on
a shuttle eventually we discovered that
our name is Peter and we work with a
company called chasma they are a
competitor of Transtar and have tasked
us with running this simulation as per
our contract details we aren't finished
until we accomplish all 27 tasks they
have given us to do in the simulation
this simulation is of a scenario that is
believed to have happened on the
Transtar Moonbase pythius and where the
majority of the content will be taking
place we are given five characters from
the base the volunteer director security
officer custodian and engineer the
ultimate end goal is completing those 27
tasks chasma has given us the moon base
is split into four sections the main
area is the crater that connects all the
other three areas in the moon base which
are the pythius labs crew Annex and the
moonworks each of these sections will be
very important for completing this DLC
as for the rules of this DLC it is a
roguelike areas will be different
different and change every time you
reset for example this one tunnel was
blocked off in one run but on the next
it was gone also when I say run I mean
simulation run the simulation can be
reset at any time you want for whatever
reason but when you reset the simulation
things will change everything you do as
characters on the map will stay but once
you reset you get put in a new version
of the map the best way to imagine it is
if there were thousands of moon bases in
front of you each of them has the same
sections of the map and the same
structures and Floors but each of them
has small tiny details that set it apart
from one another one could have
radiation in the crew Annex but another
may not when you reset the simulation
you're basically packing up and leaving
to go to another moon base it's not the
greatest analogy but hopefully that
makes sense despite how it sounds
resetting is actually a very key part of
the game as the longer you're on the
moon base the higher your corruption
level goes every level it goes up the
enemies will get stronger certain
enemies that spawn on lower levels like
mimics or Phantoms will just be stronger
versions of that enemy with a number
next to them but other Typhon like
Weavers in telepath house will only
spawn on the higher corruption levels if
things get too hard you can always reset
and start back at corruption level 1.
since we have five characters obviously
the next question is which one is better
and there's actually no answer for this
as all of them are different each of
them has different health and energy
levels as well as what they start with
and what abilities you can upgrade which
is why you need to use all of them
because some of the challenges can only
be completed with specific characters
the very last thing to go over is what
resets because at face value it sounds
like a complete sweep of everything but
that's not entirely true any characters
challenges and story objectives that are
completed will stay forever the other
two things that stay are the known
variables occurring in the moon base and
any upgrade you unlock I'll get to that
first one later but as for the latter
the neural mods in your inventory will
disappear but assuming you put them into
any upgrade across any character then
they will stay permanently so what is a
typical playthrough of the DLC look like
at the beginning of a new run you'll
pick a character at the very beginning
you'll only have the volunteer but
eventually it'll progress and unlock the
other four just selecting your character
then you can pick the loadout using Sim
points Sim points are earned by doing a
ton of things escaping killing enemies
or discovering dead bodies your Loadout
is based on the fabrication plans you've
picked up in the world as well so if you
pick up the plan for making a silence
pistol then you can buy one to put in
your Loadout once you select your
Loadout for guns ammo and chipsets you
start in a small room and are just left
to do whatever you want since those 27
tasks do not have to be completed all at
once you can take your time completing
them more in some cases dedicate an
entire run to one objective before
resetting the simulation it's
recommended that you at least get the
characters first but the rest are
entirely up to you Moonbase has very
similar things to prey so you'll find
Fabricators and recyclers as well as
Security offices with all the crew
members locations in the case of the
security officer to unlock him you need
to find his corpse on the moon base so
you could just go to a workstation and
find where he died that way even though
you don't get to keep your loadouts and
are constantly resetting the game still
provides that option of player choice
just like the main game albeit in a
different way most of your choices will
be planned out ahead of time mapping on
a route in your mind and what you want
to accomplish taking into account where
to go how to get there and what to buy
for the mission ahead the rest is made
up on the Fly since things are random
you'll never know what will happen
sometimes an area you need to go to has
no power so instead of just going to
that location you need to make a quick
pit stop to the crater and turn on the
power like I said the freedom to choose
how you want to play is there but it's
just a little bit different this time
around as I said before the goal is to
complete all 27 objectives and now that
we've finally got in the description out
of the way let's go over those
objectives they are split into four
sections crew members Escape attempts
story objectives and Discovery the crew
members are easy as you just need to
unlock the characters the Escape
attempts Encompass all the tasks
involved with escaping so you using
every method escaping with every
character and by far the hardest one
escaping using every character in one
run the story objectives are exactly as
they sound each character has a story
objective that needs to be completed in
order to finish the game and unlock this
you'll need to First unlock the
character then do the requirement at the
bottom so it'll unlock the security off
officer we need to find his body on the
moon base which we already talked about
after searching it he becomes a playable
character to unlock his story objective
we need to escape using the mass driver
once that's done we can then do his
story objective and fully complete it
the last section Discovery is more of a
mixed bag of things where you discover
all four sections of the moon base do
all five Escape Routes scan five unique
Typhon find 10 chipsets and Fabrication
plans and finally install 50 neural mods
across all the characters I know that
last one sounds really complex but it's
honestly not too bad they mean 50 neuro
mods in total so the engineer can have
49 and the volunteer has one and it will
still count as a completion also they
really mean neuromods not upgrades some
upgrades can cost you three or six
neural mods unlocking this wouldn't be
one of 50 it'd be three or six out of 50
because that's how many neural mods that
were needed to install it these are all
the objectives we need to complete so
that we can finish the DLC an idea that
some players have done is to stock up on
upgrades that you can be extremely
overpowered personally I don't think
it's necessary but regardless should you
attempt to do this you'll find out that
the game still gets harder and I'm not
just talking about the corruption levels
after certain levels of progress you'll
surpass a threshold this is when Peter
gets shot out of the simulation to do
some random task on the shuttle once you
return a note will appear before the
next run that updates you on the
simulation these are extremely important
as they can tell you what you already
know and what is new for example early
in the game this random entity named the
moon shark will randomly appear in the
game he's extremely deadly and very
similar to The Nightmare however after a
couple runs he'll be permanently there
every time you come back not once have I
started a run since he spawned where he
wasn't there this also goes for certain
hazards these aren't as specific but the
report just lets you know that they
exist if we go back to that early
example one of my runs had a radiation
Hazard at the crew Annex after a while
the idea became permanent the radiation
wasn't always at the crew Annex but the
report was telling me that a hazard like
radiation fire or no oxygen would appear
in my games permanently from now on this
is where that Randomness comes into play
so while I'm might not have the same
hazard in the same location a hazard
will more than likely appear somewhere
on the moon base but by far the most
annoying variable in this report is that
the corruption level can be two times
then three times as fast this means I
need to get things done faster than
usual or I'll be dealing with enemies a
lot quicker than I'd like as hard as it
sounds this was extremely fun as it made
me constantly come up with better routes
and ways of accomplishing my tasks while
making the completion of those tasks
really fun because they were hard it
made me feel rewarded for my effort but
it's clear from what I just described
that this DLC is definitely an acquired
taste if anything I've said in the past
seven minutes sounds too hard or not
your style you're not going to like this
DLC however if you are up for the
challenge you'll have a fantastic time
with it the story for this DLC while
light compared to the main game still
has the same good quality that the
original storyline had you don't get to
learn too much about Peter other than
that he works for chasma and was
assigned to investigate what happened on
the moon base the other pieces of story
we get are that he has a wife and
daughter the issue with this is I just
felt no reason to care about him as we
didn't even really get to know why he
was even here but our five playable
characters are much different each of
them gets their own bit of background
and story objectives so we can see what
really happened all five of them have
names and are addressed in game by their
job title so there's already established
background information the volunteer is
a man named Andreas who was just like
the other volunteers on Talos 1 and was
subjected to experiments because of this
he was able to master these new
abilities he acquired making him a
dangerous yet intriguing subject however
his story objective isn't as exciting
from his inner monologue it seems that
Andreas just wants to see his son again
our first scene from the story objective
is him being mind controlled by a
telepath the telepath is pretending to
be his son Alexi and tries to get
Andreas to retrieve his toy for him the
game automatically shoots up to
corruption level 4 but don't worry as
none of the Typhon will attack you only
The Operators if you're starting to
question how his son even got into the
moon base you're on the right track once
we get his toy we are then instructed to
get inside the Escape pod and a certain
thought starts to settle until it's
confirmed almost right away that the toy
was just a mimic and Andreas was being
deceived the volunteers have always
gotten the short stick of this game and
I was hoping for One Happy Ending but
that obviously didn't come the next
character is the director Dr Riley you
she's the cousin of both Alex and Morgan
whereas Alex became the leader of Talos
1 she became the leader of the moon base
she also has the most unique way of
escaping the moon base which is
uploading her Consciousness to an
operator then presumably shooting that
operator back to Transtar since she's
the director and leader of the base
she's a very cold and by the books woman
she got mad at one of her colleagues for
not addressing her as either Dr U or
Madame director so she clearly holds
herself to a high esteem and her
family's work reinforces that mentality
her story objective is meeting with one
of her other crewmates on the moon base
during the outbreak and activating the
Typhon Towers throughout the crater
completely eliminating any of the threat
nearby even the moon shark based on the
timing of when this took place it's
assumed that she did the story objective
first then escaped by uploading her
conscious as opposed to Andreas where
the story objective was his Escape Vijay
Bhatia is the chief of security at the
moon base and also our third playable
character he is somewhat of an easy job
compared to the people back at Talos 1
since his base isn't 700 meters long but
I'd argue in fact that he has a much
harder job than his colleague since he
was told by Dr Yu that there was a casma
mole in the base sometime earlier he
received the terrible news that his son
was killed by Bengali Pirates during a
raid in an attempt to hold back the
emotional trauma he was going through he
tried to drink the pain away and ended
up passing out he awakes to hear a very
upset doctor you yelling at him about
the chasma Spy named Claire Whitton she
seems completely unfazed by the fact
that there is an ongoing outbreak and
still insists that he kills Claire
before she escapes as she has some other
things to deal with eventually through
some Clues we find the spy's Hideout
when investigating her terminals we are
poisoned the game then tries to sell us
this option of stopping her but
sacrificing herself or saving our life
but she goes free except they gave us
way too much time to do that so so you
just end up doing both anyway once we
reach the control tower we can decide to
intervene and blow up or Shuttle or let
it take off because we completed his
story objective we also unlocked the
custodian whose requirement was to be
unlocked as vijay's story objective I
love the way this ties in together
because Clara Whitten is the custodian
but she's also the Spy she was a
custodian on the moon base but that
wasn't her official title I also love
how they purposely gave her a broom for
her Idol animation whereas when you
unlock her she gets the plasma cutter it
was a small yet a great design decision
to keep her identity a secret until the
very end Claire's story objective starts
with her stabbing some Transtar
Personnel before being contacted by
basilisk from chasma that her identity
has been made her instructions are then
to destroy all the listening devices and
plant her command key in doctor use
operator then Escape but it's a nice
little neat touch that all the listening
devices can't just be shot they have to
be recycled after finishing our taskmo
promised to extract her but they said
it'd be too costly to do that so she
needed to escape on her own our very
last character is Joan the engineer
she's an extremely skilled technician
and actually comes with a spawnable
Turret to help her fight her story
objective starts with her killing a man
with a wrench we discovered that she was
in a relationship with a man named Brian
Chung she was trying to find out what
happened to him but the man she killed
Ken wouldn't tell her it may seem
strange to resort to violence like this
but an early transcribe can provide
context to what we're about to uncover
in the same room that we stopped
Claire's shuttle as Vijay a transcribe
between Ken and Jonas found and it's
discovered that because of the combined
Construction in the moon works and the
constant rumbling in the caves Joan was
mining some rocks and a large piece fell
on Brian Ken promised to deliver him to
the trauma center and get him some help
except Ken had other plans as he had
previously worked with another employee
called Diana and owed her a favor she
cashed in the favor and Ken gave her
Brian so she could run tests on him the
results of those tests are that he is a
phantom so now things are starting to
make just a little bit more sense after
discovering this she went to Brian's
quarters to find a bird that he was
sculpting for her and decided to put it
on the Finnish statue he was going to
make of her it's a really sweet and
depressing tale all of these stories are
wonderful as it shows that there was
actual things going on within the moon
base it also managed to tie in other
characters giving context to other
actions and further providing more story
content for us to uncover the question
Still Remains though what actually
happened and we really don't know we do
know some concrete details but the rest
are up to interpretation to explain we
also need to discuss the five Escape
Routes seeing as there's only five
characters and five Escape Routes it
starts to settle in that only one Escape
is allowed per character which is why
that last objective of doing it all in
one run is all the more difficult the
first option is the shuttle and this is
by far the easiest one to complete all
you need to do is get the data to Pilot
the shuttle and the neural mods become a
pilot and you can fly off the moon base
a similar one to this is the escape pod
due to the convenience of Escape pods
many of them are gone in fact only one
of them is left you'll have to check
which location has the last one before
hopping in and escaping later the game
will require use installation Keys which
is a whole other objective except I
never did that because I just purchased
them in my loadout moving on up in
difficulty is the mass driver this is a
storage bin that's usually filled with
cargo but you're going to launch
yourself to Earth with this to survive
the trip you need some food water and
some anti-rads which once again can
either be purchased ahead of time or
found pretty much anywhere on the base
after putting in the food you need to
activate the mass drive from the control
tower then Sprint all the way down
before it takes off without you our
fourth option is uploading our
Consciousness this can only be done by
Dr U and is the only escape with a
required character to do this we need to
visit dru's computer and contact Alex
from here we need to upload some data to
this operator before we put ourselves in
the chair except the data is incomplete
to get this data we need to summon a
fandom using the Phantom Genesis ability
once again an ability only available to
doctor you after we scan it and compile
the data we can set up the operator and
upload our Consciousness except we don't
remember when I said we had to put
Claire's key in the operator well this
comes into play as it actually kills
doctor you I think this is how the DLC
started as the operator we used to start
the simulation with Peter has the
command key inside of it already our
very last Escape is easy but requires a
lot of setup and that's the mimic portal
for some reason a mimic keeps
teleporting shoes from Earth and the
researchers before the attack were
trying to figure out why to us we don't
care as it's a way off the Moon to
complete this we need to hack the
computer as there's no password
available then repair the actual chamber
before stabilizing it then jumping
through the problem is we need the hack
and repair skill Claire's the only
character in the game who can hack and
Jonah is the only one who can repair so
this requires at least two people to do
and becomes one of the biggest hurdles
in the final objective so with all the
information out there what happened like
I said there isn't much concrete info
but from what I can gather Dru uploaded
her Consciousness and died thanks to
Claire which means Claire was discovered
as the mole and completed her story
objective in fact I think all these
people completed their story objectives
except maybe Visa depending on your
choice it can seem that Claire killed Dr
U Vijay killed Claire then Visa died
somewhere later Visa story objective has
different ways of ending it so this is
the one that is up to interpretation we
do know from a transcribe that he
possibly died from a moon shark since he
was being attacked by one before it
stopped recording however that doesn't
explain how he ended up inside here this
is probably my main gripe with the
entire story with the moon base is that
it's intertwined with so many different
options that coming up with a plausible
ending doesn't even seem possible as
opposed to the story though the gameplay
was well worth the effort I had multiple
notebook pages of ideas and notes
written down during the entire
playthrough and one whole page dedicated
to doing the final run since there were
five characters and five escapes one
character would be assigned to each
Escape but minus Dr U and her
Consciousness everything else can be
done by anyone meaning people won't have
the same ending as everyone else this is
actually my main gripe with death loop
as the final run for the game was the
exact same one as everyone else's and
could not be changed but Moon crash even
in its final moments allows for that
player choice so the first thing to
consider is who goes to what escape and
in what order it's also important to
remember that any Hazard or variable the
game throws at me will probably screw up
my entire plan so I need to also make
sure the Run isn't down to the letter
after like 20 minutes of writing my plan
went as follows I started as the
custodian and ran to the pipees labs to
hack the computer afterwards she would
then run to the crew Annex and take the
shuttle I could have also taken the
Escape pod but that was another random
variable I would need to get out of the
way and wanted to get going as soon as
possible after the custodian we moved
the engineer and finished the mimic
portal before doing so she'll check to
make sure where the last pod is for the
volunteer then hop inside the portal I
got super lucky that the Pod was also in
pythius so I just made my way there with
the installation key and hopped in the
pot and left even though the volunteer
has 75 Health he has a ton of evasive
tactics like going underground
temporarily so I wasn't too worried
about the difficulty my biggest fear was
up next as Dr U would then upload her
Consciousness I planned on going to the
lounge just underneath her office
because of the plethora of food and
drinks in the room I could then use the
robot companion given to all the
characters earlier in the game to
transfer my items to everyone when I
needed to I also thought that since Dr
Yu goes passed the mass driver for
escape objective I could just drop off
the food on the way but apparently once
you get the data from The Phantom the
first time you'll never need it again
which was quite bizarre I didn't know if
this was intended or a glitch and it
definitely really didn't help my
decision when the device for the
operator never appeared until after
placing it so I thought I bugged my game
out still I was coasting around
corruption level 2 and I was feeling
Uber confident and it still ended up
working out okay as I placed the items
in immediately activated the driver then
shot bija to space this whole sequence
took around 40 minutes including the
actual gameplay and the planning ahead
of time and it was some of the most
exhilarating gameplay I've experienced
in a long time it was probably the most
fun I've had playing this entire game
after this is completed you're most
likely finished with every other
objective with all of our objectives
complete we can finally talk to chasma
about our contract and now is a good
time to talk about Peter's story Moon
crash's story is best described as okay
it's not mind-blowing but it's not
terrible either because the simulation
takes priority we don't get to see Peter
too much besides the times we hop out of
the simulation those first few times we
do hop out of the simulation we're just
told to do some random tasks like fixing
something or putting something away
eventually we will overhear a
conversation between basilisk and a
director of chasma named Teddy it seems
that Teddy is going to do what they did
declare and leave us to die when we're
done with our contract so instead
basilisk helps us by instructing us to
set aside an oxygen tank just in case
this comes in handy as when we finished
Teddy does exactly what we thought then
attempts to suffocate us so we grab the
oxygen tank and go to the command
console and events of the shuttle sadly
after trying every option we're only
able to decommission the ship and crash
it into the moon which Peter does
surprisingly though he is alive and
after leaving the rubble of his shuttle
he finds a potential way off the moon
before the credits roll but not too fast
we are playing prey after all and once
again get another post-credits scene
that plays the sound of ocean waves and
seagulls which applies Peter made it to
Earth but as you probably expected
another mimic also made it to Earth
since on the dashboard is a a duplicate
of his daughter's toy Moon crash ends on
a cliffhanger-like prey as we don't
really know what happens afterwards but
given the ending of the story it's more
than likely it leads to the Typhon
attack on Earth as a whole Moon crash is
one of the best DLCs I've played in a
long time and despite the DLC being
completely different in gameplay as the
main game it was honestly just as fun
most DLCs are a continued storyline with
the same mechanics this is seen in just
about 99 percent of DLC and there's
nothing wrong with that if people enjoy
the gameplay of the main story they're
obviously going to like the DLCs as
they're the same but Arcane took yet
again another risk in doing this and at
least for me it was worth it the same
cannot be said for others however as
completing the DLC is an achievement
that only 0.24 percent of players on
Xbox have completed even getting all the
five characters was an achievement 0.43
percent of players completed I know
Xbox's achievement percentage isn't
always perfect but that means that an
overwhelming amount of players didn't
even buy the DLC and even the ones that
did didn't make it very far the DLC
seemed to suffer a similar fate to the
main game and it's mostly the reason DLC
didn't gain any traction because who the
hell buys a game only to play the DLC I
understand that Moon crash's gameplay is
not everyone's cup of tea but just like
the main game I still wish it got more
attention
finally though we've made it to the
outro thank you all for making it this
far in the video praise a game that
despite its flaws deserve more
recognition than it got while I am a
part of that problem since I didn't buy
the game on launch I guess I'm still
kind of doing my part by sharing my
experience with all of you if it wasn't
obvious by the length I had a lot to say
about prey and a lot of that was good
things that I really enjoyed about the
game like its exploration the ending and
its DLC regardless thank you for taking
time out of your day to watch to the end
of the video and if you did let me know
if you've played a prayer or not in the
comments down below and whether or not
you enjoyed the game yourself as always
like the video If you enjoyed And
subscribe if you're new if you want to
see more video essays like this I
encourage you to check out my other
videos like the one on Fallout New Vegas
if you want to watch some other style of
content then you could watch my recent
reviews on both writer's Republic and
Far Cry 6. to my returning viewers thank
you for always coming back and with that
everyone take care and goodbye
foreign
[Music]